there are lots of ways of telling
stories and this particular pendulum
let's call it for a second in which the
Arctic is melting it's not a pendulum
that swings back like a lot a lot of
people think well eventually if it
swings this way it will swing back this
way um this doesn't automatically
refreeze and so I think we have to
imagine different ways to describe the
ends of things if we can imagine the
world before us without us we will be
able to imagine the world again without
us
and I think that not to be so dark but
we're not going to be here forever
probably we will be part of the cycle
that is it goes extinct and then it
comes back in and goes extinct again and
and the ones that and as we look back
into the deep past we we understand how
those cycles work their cycles and so of
course our stories always have kind of
good endings or goodish endings you know
like we move on so the story of
extinction is something that is too
traumatic for people to understand me
for example I'm so Andy who tells
stories to other people or if not to
that to somehow speak to the future if
there is nothing in the future nobody
there
Who am I talking to what is
about now I am a student of Buddhism so
I asked my teacher said okay how does
karma work then if their son to pass
let's say everything goes way off the
rails like it might do and and human
kindness well my types of fibers what
happens with the Karma who then takes on
the carnival of people before them where
does that energy go and he said well
that's why the Buddha talked about other
universes I was like oh I see we're not
limited to to do graphical place we
don't have to hang around earth you go
off into other the universes and you put
its energy and how does it work so we
have to I think as humans begin to think
of other ways to understand time and
understand our place in time and that
perhaps we are part of this cycle
perhaps you know and and perhaps we'll
get absorbed into that's like a looking
and that that's not the worst thing that
will have ever happened in the universe
you know it doesn't mean that I did I
expect that it also means that I I want
to do my best to be here for every
minute and to to do what I can to to
slow this situation I'm not I'm not even
know I'm like a tech person I do not
think technology is going to come in and
save us at all
I know we repaired the hole in the ozone
I know we can do like little thing those
little tricks but certain things and
more of a have more sympathy with a
writer like Timothy Morton who is says
you know it already started this this
slight and don't think you can stop it
so what do you do as a human confronting
something like that when somebody says
something like that what do you do well
this is what we all need to invent now
is what what happens when you look into
this light of like we don't know what it
is we don't know what's going to happen
you really don't know we really don't
know and so how can you walk into a
situation that you don't know
now there's one story that I like it has
to do with a Bible story and it has to
do with a lot of reevaluation of whom
Moses was okay so well as this was the
guy like help the Jews get out of Egypt
to near slaves and so in this we
evaluation of the personality of Moses
with these new texts that they're kind
of reading in a different way they said
well you know actually Moses was was
talking to the Jews and saying you know
what your sleeves and you have a slave
mentality you know you you don't have a
plan you're not ready to be free we
don't even know where we're going where
we going out into the desert that's not
a plan and I'm not the guy to lead lead
you there I'm I'm not a leader I I don't
know where we're going and you're not
ready in the huh and I'm can't do it
this thing I love about this story was
just the Exodus story is they went
anyway
that's just outing story so not knowing
where they were going they put all of
their energy into doing it so this is
the one that I'm always is in my mind
and it has to do with you know what you
would call blind faith you know just
like I'm going to do it anyway even
though I think I know what maybe the
outcome is the fact is you don't know
the outcome and I don't know the outcome
none of us know where we're going so
that what do we do each one of us has to
think the best way to do it if you're
maybe a para Y your head maybe you're
going to frantically find out how to
freeze ice again you know if you're you
know there are a million ways to think
of of what to do when you look at
something as unprecedented as this is
that the melting of our planet so I am
not pretending I know what to do and I'm
not pretending that it's okay or that
somehow it's like an emergency this is
the biggest emergency we faced as as
people on the planet and so I have to
all be great if we could all it come to
understand it and that's the best we can
do and maybe in understanding it maybe
there's a way to do something else for
that but that's it